欢迎来到我们的games 202的第五讲啊
今天我们会讲一个新话题啊
这个新话题是关于说实时的
这叫什么呢
环境光照应该怎么样去处理好吧
嗯然后呢在今天的课程之前
咱们还是说几件事情
第一呢就是作业一啊
我我以为已经发布了哈
行就算是没发布
今天肯定会发布
然后呢差不多呃有一个半星期可以做呃
这个作业啊差不多呃十天吧
这样嗯然后这次作业呢就是关于pcs的
然后大家要去实现一个正确的pcs s
在这之前还会先实现shadow mapping
这么个意思
就是差不多就是阴影的主流的思路
那么呃另外一件事情是这样的
就是我之前不是说关于4月1号的那个星期
也就是下个星期了
下个星期呃我这课要怎么个安排法呢
我之前想的是说我先录播
然后录下来
然后播出呃
但是后来呢嗯一方面有同学反映说
希望还是能够直播
另外一方面是我自己发现
我好像没什么时间在下周之前先把它给制作好
录好
所以呢那咱们就这么打算吧
那就是说呃嗯下周我们就不安排课程了
也就是说下周没有直播
也没有录播啊
下周我自己的这些呃出差的事情
等我回来回来之后
也就在下下周呃
我们会继续呃恢复我们的直播好吧
这么安排
至于说这课会不会往后再拖一个星期
会影响到siggraph asia
我之后再安排吧好吧
因为我之前嗯认为说呃
五一的那一周我是不播的
但是五一那一周我是可以录播下来对吧
嗯所以说这样的话感觉又可以省出来一个星期
所以好像还行啊
那暂时咱们就这么安排啊
下周没课
也就是说呃今天第五讲对吧
第六讲讲完
第七
第八讲将会在下下周来讲好吧
ok那这是这事儿
然后呢关于之前同学们问的
关于gains 101作业重新提交呀
重新批改呀
最后重新发证书呀
啊这个事情也是一样
等我回来之后
我就会开始启动这么一个过程
那就是呃games 101的grader
我需要去呃呃面向大家去征集一下
然后如果有同学是呃有意向来呃
就是帮后续的电上电子101的同学们
去批改作业的话啊
这块嘿嘿嘿呃呃尽早联系我吧
虽然咱们现在还没有开始发布这个
正式的正式的消息哦
对不是联系我
应该是联系到技术秘书同学
这样吧
大家稍等啊
然后等我到时候发布这个正式的消息
然后嗯大家再踊跃报名好吧
那咱们这么安排ok啊
至于什么要求什么东西
哎这之后再说吧好吧
咱们暂时现在先这么打算着好
那这就是呃课前咱们要说的事
那么上一节课咱们说了什么呢
咱们上一节课主要是说了一些关于呃
嗯就是pcs s的一些更深层次的一些理解对吧
一个非常聪明的做法
就是vs s m啊
然后也有人说是vs m一回事啊
vance soft gentlemapping
然后他呢就是针对性的去解决
pcs中第一步跟第三步
这两步呃的比较慢的这么一个问题
然后呢他非常聪明地使用了这种范围查询
然后呃就因此去避免了采样嘛
就是这么一个思路啊
然后我们又提到他的一个相当于延伸版本
对不对
然后呃引入更多的呃
就是更高阶的所谓moments这么个意思
那这就是上节课所说的内容
基本上来说啊
咱们上节课做过这个总结对吧
就是说vs s m在最近特别是在这个temporal呃
dnoisy这么一系列的方法提出之后
呃
可能用的渐渐的就没有pcs用的多
但是为什么咱们要学呢
就是说v s s m
是一个非常非常非常聪明的做法
咱们学的可以让我们更聪明
对不对
体会一下为什么别人可以想到这么精妙的算法
这个非常有趣的一件事情
好吧嗯那差不多就是这么个事情
那么今天呢咱们会先想办法把shadow这块给说完
shadow这块呢我们还缺一块知识啊
这块儿什么呢
就是说我们呃
我们的这个现在刚刚开始兴起的一种新的呃
呃生成软硬的方式叫做distance field shadow
soft
distance field south shadows啊
这么一个方式呃
然后这块我们肯定是要说一下的
因为这是我觉得吧
就最近几年内应该会得到更加广泛的一个应用
特别是这个distance field最近研究的人是非常多的
而且是跨各种领域的什么几何呀
呃渲染呀
都在研究这么一个东西啊
从不同的角度吧
什么个意思好吧
然后所以说咱们一定要说一下
非常有用的一个东西啊
那么另外一个呢就是说我们说完之后
我们就开始来讲另外一个所谓环境
光照需要解决的一些问题
然后环境光照呢是一个挺困难的一场
然后咱们今天大家会发现
这课的难度好像已经降不下来了
这我在这嗯就准备这些课程内容中
也是发现了这么一个事情啊
因为没办法像啊实时渲染这么复杂的一个话题
他就首先要求大家对这个渲染领域这就比较熟
然后才会有各种各样的操作
大家会看到这呃
今天要讲的所谓split sum这个方法
然后它是它是非常非常依赖于大家
对以前知识的理解的好看
那之后我们再继续说
好吧嗯那行
然后呢最后最后最后如果我们有时间提
据说环境光照下的阴影怎么做
哎那咱们先看这个标题哈
这标题可不是打错了
这说的清楚
就是说我们要解决的今天主要说的环境光照
要解决的是所谓shading问题
是忽略了他的shadow的时候要解决的shading
好吧
这么个意思
然后之前至于这俩什么区别
咱们之前老早就说过了
赶紧g101 对吧
ok那咱们这就开始吧
在这之前我看哈
诶有同学说我今天会不会讲spherical harmonix呢
答案是不会哈
今天不会讲
很快就会讲到啊
这个意思哈哈哈哈哈哈嗯好吧嗯
补充材料链接说得好说得好
而且我之前这几节课
是不是就应该把链接放出来了啊
有道理啊
啊这样哈
我记得这事儿
然后助教同学们之后在课后如果我忘了
记得提醒我一下
好吧
ok啊对啊
有同学说的对
今天要讲的叫做i b l之后
咱们再看具体什么意思吧好吧
那咱们先进入第一个话题
第一个话题要说什么呢
要说呃distance field of shadow
那么首先还是一样
咱们说一下为什么我们要讲distance field of shadow呢
因为这个东西可太好了
ok啊
为什么呢
大家可以看到啊
s d f呃
他的呃推特啊
还有twitter
然后说s d f shadow呢
它有什么好处呢
哎说的非常清楚
非常快对吧
比现在传统的shadow map要快
然后说说为什么堡垒之夜没有百分之百的用它
是因为它的存储是有个问题的对吧
诶那那大家就看到了一个好处又坏处了
已经对吧
首先呢它呃它很快
然后另外一个它需要大量的存储啊
然后如果说要想结合现在的技术应该怎么用
咱们这个就不多说了
好吧嗯嗯然后后面他就是说吧
就是说这后面的啊
如果有一个非常复杂的这种几何
然后我其实呢我用sdf shadow可以达到嗯
这是非常复杂的几何才能达到的效果
然后我得用三个shadow map才能做到的效果
哈哈哈说这事儿
所以呢不管怎么样啊
这是非常好的
然后后面总结说
还不会有这些什么自遮挡问题啊
没有什么呃这些阴影的悬浮的这个问题啊
咱们之前都提过
对不对
ok那这就是为什么我们要说这distance field啊
然后呃呃然后咱们先看一下效果吧对吧
先看一下distance field soft shadow
那他顾名思义了
他首先他要做的肯定是软硬硬的生成对吧
然后大家看左边这幅呢
就是用所谓的distance fields来生成的啊
这么一个软阴影
然后大家看效果非常不错嘛对吧
然后比起这个所谓hot shadow效果要好很多
那么它到底是个什么意思对吧
咱们之前在game 101简单提过呢
那么distance field或者是distance function
这是一回事
然后他是干什么的呢
它定义了啊
在空间中的任何一个点
空间中的任何一个点
他去定义啊
他到某个物体的表面上呃
最近的一个点的距离
或者说它到物体表面的最小距离啊
这是完全是一回事
对不对
然后呢这个距离长呃
signed distance function
它有可能把它给定义成一种呃带带正负号的
带正负号是什么意思呢
就是在物体内部
比如说我规定呃它得是负号
然后在物体外部它得是正号
这样的话呢它不只定义了一个距离
还定义了一个所谓有向距离
所以说嗯通常我们说距离场
然后我就直接把它给缩写成s d f
它不管它是不是有像哈
然后就是说呃我就这么说了
好吧
sdf我指的就是这么一个距离场
那咱们下面看到有两个这个例子哈
啊就是大家可以从这个图上推断
就可以看得出这是什么对吧
这这就是字母a哈哈的这么一张图
他的呃距离场
那也就是说啊呃这张呃这a的字母啊
打到了一个图上
然后这个图上的任何一个点呢
我都可以计算这个点到呃
比如说字母a的轮廓上对吧
在这二维的情况下
我们说物体表面那是什么
那就是物体轮廓对吧
到物体的轮廓上最近的一个距离是多少
那么呃这两种仅仅是不同的可视化方式
左边呢就是把它的值直接给打印出来
大家可以看到在这个a的内部的时候
它就把它显示成黑的
然后在这个a的外部的情况下
也可以看到
那随着不同的点离这个a字母越来越远
它的值应该越来越小对吧
看起来就像是一个很模糊的一个东西
诶非常有意思的事
然后呢啊啊右边是另外一种可视化方式
这种可视化方式被广泛应用在地图上啊
这前咱们games 101都说过对吧
这是类似等直线的一种方式
类比于地图的等高线嘛
就是同样的一个颜色表示的值是一样的
大家可以看到
基本上就是这个呃轮廓往外扩了一圈儿
一圈儿嘛对吧
所以说啊distance function它就是这么定义的啊
这个意思ok嗯好我先看一下啊
嗯嗯有同学说这个符号距离函数嗯行挺好的吧
我觉得翻译的不错
s d f t度哦
对之前上一次就是同学说了这事
后来想了一想
不讲了
不讲这节课东西有点多啊
sdf梯度不讲啊
说清楚
ok那咱们啊这就开始吧
ok下一个话题就是什么呢
就是说我为什么要用这sdf呢
因为s d f是非常非常有用的一个东西
然后咱们之前在game 101里面
做过这么一个例子哈
做过什么一个例子
之前我画的不怎么清楚
于是呢我重置了这么一个这样ppt啊
大家可以看一下我这个例子是想干什么呢
我这个例子是想去呃
所谓去blend一个运动的边界好吧
咱们可以认为这个a和b呢它就是两张图
然后这张图呢
它左半边它有一个物体刚刚移进了这个图
并且这个物体呢它在从左往右再移动啊
这么个过程好吧
那么假设在这个a所代表这个时刻
而这个物体在这
大家大家可以看到这边界啊
就是这个黑与白之间的这么一个分界线
这个边界在这
在大概在靠左的这1/3的部分吧
啊这里对吧
然后呢这个物体在另外一个时间诶
它移动到了某个位置在这
然后大家可以看到哦
它的边界呃
移动到了这里好
那我们这两幅图都可以得到吧
我假设说可以拍这么两张图
对吧好
那我拍下了这两张图之后哦
那我如果可以把这两张图做一个线性的差值
什么线性差值啊
每一个像素咱们说清楚
每一个像素都取在对应的a的位置
和对应的b的位置
然后它的值
然后中间做一个所谓线性的一个平均
咱们就认为50%
50%的平均好吧
那这样会造成一个什么结果
大家看就得到右边这张图了对吧
线性差值a和b
那这样的话
大家看到左边这1/3为什么是黑的
因为这是任何一个点
在这a也是黑的
b也是黑的
没错吧
比如说咱们鼠标停的这个位置
这个位置在a之前是黑的
在b之前是黑的
那最右边也好理解
我鼠标停的这个位置呢
它在呃a之前
他他在这个位置是白的
b这个位置也是白的
然后在这中间坏了
这就出事了对吧
什么时候呢
大家会发现哦
在这里之前在这a的位置上白的
在b的这个位置上黑的
然后他一平均好了
变灰了
那就变成了这么一张图对吧
哎所以说我我简单地对它得到这么两张图啊
做一个平均
我并不能得到一个移动的呃
一个一个边界
对不对
哎
我得到的这个东西
就看起来就像是它形成了一个灰色的一个
过渡带了一样对吧
这个意思
所以这自然不是我想要的咯
那我想要的是什么呢
或者说有什么办法可以让我还是做这种呃
线性差值
但是我却可以得到一个在中间的一个边界呢
对不对
那这个时候呢咱们看一下
如果说我们可以把a给转变成一个呃
所谓它对应的s d f
咱们刚才说了s d f嘛
有有效的距离吗
那么我们定义在物体内部呢
也就是黑的部分
假如说他颜色它都是都是
这叫什么呢
都是是负值啊
然后在右边都是正的值
然后随着它的值
随着它啊这点的不同位置啊
离边界的不同位置
然后我可以给它一个不同大小对吧
这是没问题的
那所以说a转换成对应的s d f它是长这样
那同样楼里b转换成sdf
它长什么样的
长这样对吧
然后大家可以看到s d f什么时候是零呢
就在这边界上是零
然后在左边呢它就是负的
再右边就是正诶
那这个时候如果我把sdf啊
这俩s df给重新做一个线性差值
还是一样
在任何一个点我都计算哦
它在a这个地方sdf的值
然后在b这个地方s d f的值
并且求于平均诶
那这样的话我得到一个什么呢
大家看这条线啊
这条线正好在中间诶
那我之前取呃
在a对应这个中间的位置
它大于零的
假如说它的值是五
然后呢我去找这个b对应在在这中间这个位置
然后它就值多少
假如他是-5
唉然后我发现它正中间正好应该是零对吧
诶
那所以说我得到了这么一个差值
之后的这么一张图
然后插值之后
这张图呢之后我再根据他sdf所表示的性质
对sdf什么时候表示的是物体的边界呢
在sdf等于零的时候是物体的边界
在这个时候我就会恢复出这么一幅图来
然后我发现哦
原来如此
我还是线性去插值哎
对应的s d f
然后我再恢复出来一个结果
那这个时候就反映了阴影在移动啊
非常有意思的一个事情对吧
那也就是说啊它有一个非常不错的性质
它可以表示物体的边界啊
虽然咱们这节课用不着啊这个意思
然后这就是说人们喜欢这个啊
distance function是因为什么呢
因为它可以做任意不同形状的一种
一种所谓不ending
而呢你不需要去关注这个哎
你不需要去关注他们之间的所谓拓扑的关系
比如说大家可以看到诶
我有两个不同的s d f
然后大家可以看到很明显的一个球
在像一个这这正方形去移动对吧
然后如果说我们把他们两个各自都转换成a
distance field
然后我再去blend诶
然后呢
我我就可以把他们最后最后给融合到一块
这是非常有趣的一件事情
对不对
所以说他可以得到几何上的一个
非常好的一个过渡
那这也是为什么人们会喜欢这个sdf啊
这个意思啊
那么这个时候呢我多说一句吧
既然这是一个提高课
这个sdf呢
它的背后和一个理论是非常非常有关系的
这个理论叫做optimal transport
叫最优传输这块儿呢
这个顾险峰老师研究得非常透彻了
这是呃应该是能够找到非常不错的一些资料
好吧
然后咱们就简单说一下
就叫做optimal transport或者叫最优传输啊
这个理论嗯
就是说这块呢也是算是学术前沿
我个我个人来说也是哎非常呃
对这方面也有兴趣
不过呢我是希望把它给弄到
这是在rendering的层面上能够有一些应用啊
当然也也也在研究中吧
可以这么说好吧
呃咱们回到distance field的这个呃事情上来
那么distance field有了对吧
然后呢我们怎么用呢对吧
那那首先呢给大家提供一个呃
最简单的一个用法
也是他的第一种用法
第一种用法叫什么呢
大家耳熟能详的呃
ray marching
ray marching是一个经典的去所谓呃去用光线追踪
然后一去追踪一个距离场
然后看我会打到哪个物体表面这么一个思路哈
然后呢啊这个之前呢咱们101里面并没有说
所以这里面简单提一下呃
但是我知道201简单提了一下对吧
就是说因为它实在太简单了
这个即便不是running领域
我觉得这块也是非常非常好理解的哈
就假设说啊整个场景的sdf你已经得到了好吧
然后你有这个sdf之后呢
你现在有一根光线
因为这根光线你试图去嗯做一个事情
就是这个光线和sdf所定义的隐含表面
去做一个求教
这怎么样怎么样去求教呢
那这个时候提供一个方法叫做sphere tracing
这是一个最最简单的直接的一个方式
那么它的一个最最有意思的一个思想是什么呢
就是说他背后是是用了这么一个规律
什么规律呢
咱们比如说这个这个位置哈
你这个s d f它到底告诉你一个什么样的信息
那s d f咱们刚才定义什么来着
就是说这点到呃
比如说这个场景中其他的这个物体
它的最小的距离
那那既然是最小距离
那说明什么呢
比如说在这一点
他告诉我哦
这是他到场景中其他物体的最小距离
并且咱们知道在这儿对吧
但是呢它隐含着告诉我们这么一个事情
也就是说在这么一个最小距离之内
你不管这个这个点它往哪儿去
他无论如何不可能与任何物体相交
否则就意味着
一定有一个物体在这个范围里面了
所以那这个s d f就就记录的纸质
不对的对吧
就是这个意思
也就是说啊
它任何一个点嗯
上它的sdf的值
就给你定义了一个任意的安全距离
不管你往哪个方向走
你只要走的距离不超过这个距离
它一定不可能与任何物体发生碰撞
是不是一个非常这个聪明的一个一个想法对吧
哎那就可以利用这么一个思路啊
我们为了去做re s d f tracing对吧
是这么个意思
那我一开始有个光线
它的起点在这儿
它往这个方向去
那我一开始就看他起点上告诉我s d f是多少
那df告诉我哦
大概是这么大
然后告诉我这么大的话
那我就可以放心的把这个呃
这个点给移到它对应的这个方向
然后走那么长距离这么个地方
因为我知道这个时候它一定不可能发生任何的
相较对吧
然后在这一点呢
我又可以查到他一个s d f
我又知道他往前面走
那他的s d f的直邮告诉我
我可以往前走多少的安全距离
是不是这个意思
所以说直到我一往往前走
走到什么时候停呢
那我就走到要么和这个物体足够接近了
也就是说它的sdf小到一定程度对吧
要么我光线已经往前去踹死了非常远的距离了
我还什么都没踹死到呢
那我就不要了对吧
就扔了
差不多就是这么两种思路对吧
所以说这是非常聪明的一个做法对吧
然后咱们总结一下意思
就是说不管任何时候你在p点啊
假设任何时候你在p点
然后这个p点你都可以从这个p点
往你给定的方向
还有去嗯
往前走呃
往前走
s d f of p那么个距离对吗
就是这个意思好
那这就是他的啊
就是使用方法一吧啊咱们来看看哈
有同学说什么啊
哦有同学说算sdf是吗啊
ok那这块是我刚才没说了
就是说我这里是假设说sdf就已经有了吗
那sdf咱们我是想着
咱们在最后它的不足的地方
我们再说他这个事情哈
那现在提一下也可以吧
就是你这样想吧
sdf它的本身的定义
是不是就定义在空间中任何一个点
然后他要定义到呃
你这比如说场景中任何物体表面的最小距离
对不对
那也就意味着sdf如果在一个三维场景中
sdf可是一个三维的一个值
对不对
他任何一个点嘛
所以说嗯嗯你要是想表示所有的这些面啊
然后呃他其实是二维的嘛
咱们之前说过对不对
考虑一下texture mapping
那那么你要是sdf的话
那就是这个场景中任何一点
你首先就得先把他s df给算出来
然后呢你要把它算出来之后
你还要涉及到存储
你要存储一个3d的一个呃巨大无比的格子
要覆盖整个场景
是不是非常大的一件事情对吧
当然这中间有优化了
但不管怎么样
反正这个存储是非常高的
咱们在一开始这个推特就见到了
对不对
说它的存储是个问题啊
那咱们讲完这块之后
我简单跟大家聊一下
聊一下现在有什么有什么方法再做呃
sdf存储的压缩或者其他东西
好吧
这个意思呃
运动的物体是实时计算s d f吗
这个问题是非常好的
那么哎也是一样
它其实是s d f的一个局限的东西
就是运动的物体是可以的
s d f是可以用的
没有问题呃
但是形变的物体是不行的
形变的物体就是说你得保证啊
把这个物体的sdf就得重新算一遍呃
至于说他这重新算一遍呃
需要多大开销
有没有办法能根据它的形变
然后我只需要计算它改变了的部分
那这就是另外的事情了
那就是几何这边在研究的事情了
好吧
那么刚才我我为什么说
运动的物体其实是可以的
如果是刚体运动的嗯
这这个事情呢其实是一个sdf的一个非常好
非常好的一个性质什么的
比如说你场景中有多个物体
你每一个物体都单独算了一下他们的s d f
那你现在要做光线和整个场景的求教
你在任何一个点的位置上啊
你其实就只用去呃去取所有这些物体中
s d f最小的那个就可以了
为什么呢
因为这个道理是显而易见的嘛
就是说嗯大家可以看到每一个物体都告诉你哦
我当前的这个位置
然后离这个物体最小的一个点
那么我如果取所有物体在当前这个点上
它的sdf的值的最小值
那不就是等于是在这个场景中
我这个点呃离场景中的任何一个物体
它的最小的距离嘛
对不对
这个最小是非常好用的一件事情
所以说呢呃就是多个物体
只要取最小的sdf就好了没
但是话又说回来
刚才我说的形变的物体确实不好做啊
这是这是这么一个意思吧
好吧啊那行
那咱们回到这个话题上面来
呃刚才提到说呃
它的最直接的应用就是所谓ray marching
那么咱们今天要介绍的就是它的第二个应用
第二个应用是什么呢
用它来生成呃软阴影
那么用它来生成软阴影是什么意思呢
那咱们之前说最早最早说的时候
game z101 就提了
说软阴影怎么来的呀
是不是就是因为有一个面光源
然后他有很多东西啊
它有一部分吧被挡住了对吗
然后它被挡住了多少
那自然就是最后的visibility的值是多少
诶我想想一减visibility值是多少对吧
就是这个意思
那么呃所以说呃在这里呢
我们可以用s d f来近一似的
得到一个大概有多少范围会被挡住
这么一个信息
然后但是它是不准的
咱们先说清楚不准的
但是是挺挺
这个符合咱们的一个一个一个观察的好吧
那这是什么意思呢
这里再看
这是呃最重要的一个理解是什么呢
就是说啊之前在第一步
他会给你个安全距离吗
这里就往后稍微推一步
这这个理解是这样的
他的sdf他告诉了你一个安全角
都什么安全角度
咱们大家看右边这幅图
那右边这幅图说明了什么问题呢
诶我有一个假如说我有一个所谓shading point
然后我往往某一个方向去打了一根光线啊
我打了一根光线
然后这个时候沿着光线中间有一个点
大家看到了吗
这个点上假如说呢他有一个呃s d f的值
它有s d f的值
告诉你哦
这个点周围大概多多远是没有障碍物的
是这意思吧
那么这个时候就可以告诉我们
如果你从这个所谓shading point网
大概这么一个方向看啊
大家看shading point往这个方向看
那我其实可以稍微偏一点
我再再多偏一点
我一直偏到这个位置上对吧
偏到这个方向上
然后我觉得都不会看到障碍物
没问题
这还是刚才的所谓安全距离的一个呃
简单的一个延伸
把它变成了一个所谓安全角度对吧
我往左边偏这么些都不会有什么物体挡住
那我再往左边偏一些
那就会呃被挡住了一些了
那就是这么个意思了
那呃随着刚才这么一个理解呢
我们就可以得到一个非常非常有用的一个观察
什么呢
就是说如果你在呃某个shading point上
往一个方向上去
你得到的这个所谓safe angle
就是就是这这个角度吧
这个角度越小
就意味着你呃能够看到的东西越少
就是这么意思
或者说你看到的这个阴影就越黑嘛
就是这个意思吧
这没问题对吧
所以说呃这里呢就是相当于是简单的把嗯
s d f可以给你的一个所谓安全角度
把它给转换成了最后阴影的值啊
就这么一个简单思路哈对吧
咱们再再再回顾一下这个事情啊
如果说你在这一个点
然后它的安全距离告诉你它有很大的圆
然后就意味着一个很大的安全角度
有很大的安全角度
说明你往这个方向去看过去啊
你看一个呃挺大的一个光源
你可能中间都没有任何遮挡对吗
那就意味着你最后可见性基本就接近一一对吗
哎那如果说这个范围呢呃它非常小
就像这种情况下
你再往左偏那么一点
那那那就那就会出现一个遮挡的情况了
那就那就说你在这种情况下呃
就是说如果你再trace一个
比如说还是刚才一般大的一个光源吧
那这里就意味着这个光源
有很多东西要被挡住了
那就意味着说你的vb会减小对吧
那基本上来说就是这么个思路嘛
那也就是说我们其实要关心的
就是在这个remarching的过程中
然后我如何去得到这么一个所谓安全角度对吧
那这个安全角度大家看这幅图就可以看到了
嗯就是假设说啊你是从呃这个o点出发
然后呢你每次往前走那么一点
还是刚才的retracing
你沿着某一个方向去这个方向呢
你就给大家可以理解成
好吧
然后往这个方向去看看
这种遮挡情况到底是什么样的
那么我我往前走
大概走到了p一啊
p一告诉我应该走到p2
p2 告诉我应该走到p3 诶
那么在这个过程中诶
我在p一的这个位置上
我是不是可以得到一个圆
得到一个圆
这个是蓝色的对吧
然后我从这个起点
我可以做一个蓝色的这个圆的切线
我就可以求出来这个蓝色的角度c大一
这就是它的呃这个点上的安全安全角度对吧
然后呢
我在这个p2 这块形成了一个偶红色的这个圆
在这个红色的圆呢
我一样我可以从起点做一条切线过来
然后诶我是红色的圆呢
这么这这么一想切
我就得到了红色的这么一个角度
呃
这个这个角度哦
那我每一个点我是不是可以这么做
那我这些点都各自可以求出来一个
所谓安全距离
那总共的安全距离啊
安全距离
安全角度
安全角度是多少呢
那自然就应该是最小的
这个角度才是安全的角度吧对吧
那呃现在就是这么个问题了
就是说我们现在知道哦
我在锤子的过程中
每一步我都算一个呃它的安全角度
我到时候取最小
这个角度一定上
一定程度上就能给我一个所谓这个阴影
到底是偏黑还是偏白
这么一个估计好吧
那留下来一个问题
什么我们怎么算这个角度对吧
那么大家从这个图上可以看到
这个角度是挺好算的
为什么呢
因为你就再算一个圆的切线嘛
在空间中就是一个球的切线嘛对吧
然后呃这个切线怎么算呢
大家知道这个s d f的距离
告诉你是这个直角边对吧
然后这个斜边就是你走的距离
然后所以说你只需要算一个ark sign就可以了
对不对
哈哈哈哈呃然后呃自然是可以这么算
但是呢哎这个时候给大家精神污染一下
ok是这样哈
虽然可以这么算
但是呢
通常人们在shader里面是很愿意去
避免一些非常复杂的运算
比如说这种反三角函数
它们的运算量就非常的大
大家就非常不喜欢这么一个呃啊这个东西啊
不喜欢这个
那么呵呵呃怎么办呢
所以呃就呃人们很聪明的提出了这么一个呃
做法
什么做法
咱们先不要管这个minimum.零的问题
咱们就看这中间这块在干什么对吧
然后大家看啊
之前arc sin在干嘛
就刚才那个直角边
就是s d f长度除以你的斜边长度
就走不多远嘛
t减o嘛
就是这个距离啊
唉等一下啊好吧
这里忘了加这个长度了哈
这不是向量哈
这个向量的长度哈啊距离啊
ok这里也一样
就是两个距离相比吧
那么一定程度上人们就是这样说
这两个比值就已经可以说明
这个角度到底大还是小了对吧
我干嘛要算那么精确
我算这个2x3 a这个东西对吧
没必要对吧
所以说呢
我这里就是说我完全可以就用这个比值
就是刚才那个s d f的值
就是安全距离除以我走过了的距离
这就算是一个对这个角度的一个近似
我在上面再乘上一个k就可以了
然后最后呢我为了把它给转换成一个visibility
它不应该能超过一对吧
就是就是这个意思吧
啊好吧
所以说大家做了一个呃
这种就是说我上面随便乘上某一个k
然后我最后得到最后的值
我再跟一点去比较
取最小就好了
那么这个有什么好处呢
这里就是说大家可以看到
就是这个k的作用到底是在干什么
这个k的作用是这样的
就是说我既然最后反正要把它砍到一点
如果说我的k的值原本诶他就是一的话
那就什么也不做嘛
那我最后就是用这么一个比值
然后他大概在0~1这么一个范围
然后我会得到的最后的结果呃
它的阴影的值诶就是0~1这么一个范围
这是没有问题的
那么嗯如果我有一个比较大的k
比如说k我取五
那也就是说这个比值呢在0.2的时候
其实我就认为它的值已经达到一了
再大它也它也还就是一了对吗
也就是说这个比值我就只看0~0点二之间
这么一比值
而这个比值会告诉我哦
呃它的阴影会从零变到一
那如果我k我取100
那我基本上来说就是就这个这个比值
在0~0点一之间
然后我就我就认为说呃0~0点零一之间啊
我就认为哦这块就是它的所谓过渡带对吗
然后它它的阴影值会从0~1
那么大家就发现了一个问题
就是这个k的作用是在干什么呢
k大的话很小的安全角度也会被你当成是一
那么零和一之间的过渡带自然而然就会少
那那也就是说在一个极端的情况下
k极大的情况下
你就可以认为哦
这种情况下就是完全是硬阴影了吗
要么零要么一了嘛
它中间过渡非常非常的小嘛
那所以说这种情况下
k呢大家已经可以猜测出来是在干什么了
k就是在控制这个阴影的软硬程度
好吧
哎这是一个非常聪明的做法嘛
就是说我要通过这个k去决定说到底有多大
一个角度内是这个软阴影的角度嘛
就是这个意思
什么时候是完全在阴影内
和完全不在阴影内的一个过渡
我就这么简单的用一个k来做了
那这是一个非常聪明的一个做法嘛
然后呃如果是我来做的话啊
如果是我来做
我估计想不到这么一个做法
如果是我来做的话
我为了减少它中间这么一个0~1的
一个过渡带哈
我的想法应该是应用一个所谓
sigmoid一样的函数
那这款机器人现在很火的对吧
所以sigmmoid我就再也不解释它是什么了
西格诺伊德的作用是什么
大家想象一下
如果我有一个线性的一个函数
我应用了一个sigmoid
我的值会不会被拉到两个极端对吧
一个是偏零
一个是偏一
这不正是我想要的吗
不是正正是想把中间的这个过渡带
尽可能的把它给缩小嘛
只不过呢sigmoid的计算它是非常非常麻烦的
然后他肯定不如说你就乘上那么一个k
然后取一个这个和一点取最小对吧
不管怎么样
这里哈大家知道这个k的作用就好了
这个k的作用就是为了减少这个扮演的一个呃
可可能产生外形的一个区域
那这个区域被减少的越厉害
那阴影就越硬嘛对吧
那所以说咱们就是这么一个解释方法
那么现在我看又有同学啊
这样吧
我先把这块说完好吧
那么说这么半天的话
就是说呃这个distance field到底应该长什么样对吧
咱们可以看一下
对于这个场景来说
大家可以看到这个场景
每一个物体应该都是有一个distance field的
然后这些distance field就可以合在一块儿
咱们刚才说的对吧
都取最小就可以形成整个一个场景的distance field
那么这distance field大概就是一个
看起来像是物体描了边一样的对吧
呃咱们刚才说了
为什么对吧
它基本上就是沿着轮廓往外面长嘛
然后越来越小嘛
这个值呃
唉然后大家看到的就是这么一个东西啊
ok啊那么这里基本上就是说呃关于这个distance
field shadow是什么意思哈
好
然后呢
有同学说
这里是不是应该应该有两个安全角度对吧
刚才咱们画了这半边
另外半边对吧
所以说这是一个非常非常大胆的近似嘛
对吧哈哈哈哈
基本上来说
就是随着刚才那么一个观察来来说的
就是呃如果说你在某一边
而i s d f本来就不能告诉你它方向在哪
咱们回回两页吧
好吧嗯
假设是这样
那你在这里呃
sdf告诉你有个安全角度
你其实真的不知道说阴影会出现在这边
还是出现在右边对吧
那如果是一个3d的情况下
你根本不知道它会出现在哪一个圆环里面去
对吧
是不是这个意思
它只你只能说呃
我大概知道这个遮挡物
大概是在呃这一圈之外对吧
然后应该是在这个圈上哼
然后你你是不知道他在哪了
你既然不知道的话
那基本上来说你你这张图
它自然你看到的是一边
那其实你不知道的情况下
你就认为是整个一个情况了对吧
然后所以说这种情况下
不去考虑这个遮挡物的位置
其实是有道理的
没什么问题哈啊ok好
我有同学问
是不是每一个点都要保存一套距离上
哎这里说的不对吧
每个点会保存一个值
那就是他s d f的值
它既然是一个厂对吧
它在三维空间中任何一个地方都有一个值哦
说起来距离场
距离场其实说的是场是不对的啊
就是说他其实按物理意义上来说
它只有一个值
它并没有方向啊
它并不应该是一个什么场
诶还是说我理解错了
厂是分所谓什么向量场合和那个厂的标量场的
啊
对他是是他是个标量场啊
那所以说它还是长啊
那是我错了啊
ok也就是随口一说啊
ok啊嗯为什么面光源一条线就可以算了
不是同学是这样的
就是说这里是假设是这么一个概念
它仅仅是为了告诉你说哦
这个距离场给你定义的安全角度
基本上来说能够告诉你说
如果这有个面光源
大概他是这么大
然后它大概有百分之多少是挡住
其实我们最后需要的仅仅是说这个角度的大小
本身能决定阴影的软硬啊
这么一个思路就是他并不需要说
我一定得在这儿考虑一个呃
真正的这么大的一个光源
然后它大概覆盖的角度是多少
然后我这边安全角度是多少
我算一个比值
然后我认为呃
一这些所谓遮挡物会均匀的分布在呃
比如说这左边一列和右边一溜
或者是不需要啊
这么理解一下就可以了
就是说你的安全角度越大
嗯得到的这个结果就应该会越软嘛
呃就这样说
得到的结果就应该越接近
完全没有被遮挡啊
这个意思得到的结果就是更偏白
然后如果说你这个安全角度非常小的话
你得到的结果就会越来越偏黑嘛
这样理解好吧行了
那咱们这边呃这个问题就说到这儿
就大家可以看到
这又是一个非常非常大胆的近似嘛
然后大家更进一步理解到说哈哈哈
实时渲染中间到底有多少各种各样的介词
那咱们总结一下哈
距离场去做呃
软阴影的话
它有很多好处
第一非常快
这个快呢相相对谁来说呢
相对于说我要直接去啊
怎么说呢
两点吧
第一是这样
如果我我去做remarching
我去求所谓光线和一个隐含的一个表面的焦点
嗯在这个基础上
我是可以自然而然的就引入嗯
这么一个软阴影的对吧
然后我我同样我可以假设说我有一个所谓shadow ray
然后往光源的中心去打
然后通过这种方式
我可以快速的得到一个呃软阴影
那么这个软阴影呢和硬阴影它的这个复杂程度
在ray marching的体系下是没有任何区别的
所以我们说它非常的快
这是没有问题的
那么另外一点是有人说啊
这里啊嗯他这个快其实它是不是一个公平比较
为什么呢
刚才我们看那个推特啊
不是说呃它会比真正的shadow map要快嘛
但其实嗯其实在这里的比较是忽略了
说呃呃就是距离场的生成的时间的啊
然后你如果只去用它的话
那只需要做remarching
那是非常快的
没问题
在shader里面就可以写remarching
但是呢shadow map通常大家跟shadow map比较的时候
我生成shadow map
这个时间才是大头对嘛
就是说我查询的map
大家知道就是一次texture query嘛
非常快的嘛
啊如果说我要做软阴影的
就是若干次也不慢的对吧
然后但是呢大家想如果我要去做ram marching
也就是几次去查询sdf而已
所以说sdf非常快
然后呢他如果呃跟这个呃嗯shadow map
在不考虑生成他们的情况下
那这是差不多快的
应该这么理解啊
但是shadow map主要花时间是花
花在生成学都买不上
因为你要把整个场景在rua一遍吧
这么个意思好吧
那么这就是呃这个事儿
然后之前我说了
就是呃嗯叫什么呢
就是说他也有他的问题吧
就是嗯大家可以看一下sdf的话
如果我去生成阴影的话
那首先就是咱们刚才说的
那它生成s d f
这本身是一个预计算的过程嘛
然后呢生成了之后
我又要把它给嗯给给存下来对吗
然后我把它存下来
对于静态的场景
静态的或者刚体这些都是可以的
没问题
然后对于动态的物体还不行
我这计算还得所谓嗯
就是说如果有一些形变的话
就得重新算它的距离场
这是非常麻烦的一件事情对吧
然后呢我距离场的存储
不管是对于什么样的物体
我算出来之后
这可是三维的
三维这个东西存储就非常的麻烦
对不对
那差不多就是呃这么个意思
然后呢实际上它还会有一些artifact
不过我这里就不再多说了
s d f有一些什么在接缝处
各种各样的artifact的情况
嗯这里是工业界比较关心的一个事情
当然不影响说我s d f能够给我
一个非常不错的一个高质量的一个软硬啊
这么个意思好
然后这里这里这样吧
我再多说一句吧
好吧
那就是说呃我们之前就说这sdf呀
它生成之后是一个三维的一个一个啊长
然后它在三维空间中
任何一个点都要记录一个值
然后这不是非常非常麻烦的吗
如果我要存的话
我把把整个场景
然后我给非常密集的踩很多的点对吧
然后这些点上它的sdf的值到底应该是多少
然后我把它存下来
我要等于存一个三维纹理嘛
非常非常大的一个存储
那么人们自然不想通过这种方式来存储
那么现在的一些方法在研究吧
有一些是这样的
就是对于场景
类似呃hierarchy的一个东西啊
之前咱们都说过
像什么kdj啊
像什么呃
嗯这些任何空间划分的八叉树呀
像什么别的一些什么书都可以嗯
不同树形结构
然后我在不断往下划分的过程中
有一些这些格子啊
基本上来说离这场景中绝大多数物体都非常远
既然离得非常远
但我根本就没必要计算或者没必要存了对吧
它呃这个值就可以认为是非常大啊
就是就是这样的话
整个一个点啊
整个一个节点
它表示一个范围内我都没必要算的非常准
那按照这种方式
我继续往下划分
直到划分到我在物体的边缘那些地方啊
就是说distance field
它的值可能在一个node里面
变化非常剧烈的情况下
我就划分的非常厉害
那这样的话我就最后形成了也一棵树嘛对吧
然后我就只需要把这复杂的这些嗯
呃s d f的值存在这些说的叶子节点上
以及说我要认为说如果啊在一个非叶子节点上
它是嗯一个常数的一个s d f
那也是可以的
没有问题
就是说我可以定义一种hierarchy
自然是这样的
办法吧
这个事情啊毫无意义啊
这个意思
这我相信没问题
但通过这种方式只会增加他的
就是所谓解压缩的时候的负担
就是你到时候要查询sdf
而且是要频繁查询
而每一次查询需要过一遍神经网络的话
那这个方法就不会不可能再有人用了
这么个意思哈
嗯差不多
这是我的一个理解啊啊ok然后我看看哈
有同学有什么问题啊
这
这这
我先把这最后一个有趣的一个东西告诉大家哈
我发现了一个github的一个项目
我不知道大家是不是这个项目已经非常有名了
还是怎么说
诶
但是这个项目是说你可以去在啊
实时渲染中间去做一个啊
做什么呢
做一个完全没有锯齿的
或者说完全无限分辨率的字符
大家都知道
如果我要在嗯
比如说一个场景里面3d的场景里面
我在墙上我要显示一个字符怎么办
我要贴图对吧
我要用texture
texture肯定是要有分辨率限制的嘛
那如果说我可以把之前的一些字母
什么都转换成sdf的话
s df我如果在嗯比较精细的层级
我还可以用一些什么曲线
什么东西去拟合它
然后我就等于说
我可以得到一个非常非常不错的一个嗯
就是抗锯齿轮的啊
这种呃就是在实时渲染中间的字符吧
这么个意思啊
我刚才说的不对哈
不是拿什么曲线去拟合
而是去插值
做一个类似于平滑的一种过渡
比如什么三线性差值之类的东西啊
这样的话就不管怎么样
任何的分辨率离得远
离得近哈
都可以看到非常清晰的字体边界
挺有意思的一个项目啊
简单的大家说一说
那么ok这里我来回头看看
有同学们嗯问了什么问题吗
ok哦有同学说计算空间中某个点的距离
尝试要遍历所有物体吗
而不需要吧
对就是说嗯就完全可以每个物体单独算
然后最后按照任何一个点
都是所有物体距离场的最小值嘛
咱们这么来算
然后我有同学说这几节课来下来感觉全是近似
没问题
同学这一直到这这门课的结束都全是近似
但是哈是这样
就是说近似的目的
那肯定就是为了让他快嘛
但是近似首先不会牺牲特别大的质量
另外这些近似都非常的聪明
对不对
ok sdf到底好不好用
sdf在做阴影的时候非常好用啊
没问题啊
嗯至于在其他的方面上有没有什么问题
就就是说sdf生成的这个物体表面
非常不好贴纹理啊
就是它的uv或者说它的参数化是不好得到的
这块来说
现在大家在积极的研究中啊
呃s d f其他的东西好吧
其他东西我就不再说了啊
咱们就简单说一下
他对这块这块儿实时渲染中的
软阴影的一点帮助吧
这么个意思
因为因为sdf它是确实是一个跨领域的东西嘛
就是说呃单独讲
我我自己来说也不可能知道的这么多啊
我就简单说到这儿吧
至于它的生成真的s d f的生成
s d f的其他应用
确实都是其他领域在研究的东西了
我们就假设说呃在running这边
我就认为他是直接可以拿到的一个信息
好吧好嘞嗯行吧
嗯那那就这样吧
好吧嗯这块咱们就说到这儿
那因为后面还有一个非常重要的一块
诶刚才有同学说sdf得到是真的阴影吗
并不是吧
s df得到的阴影会更加的虚假的
哈哈这个意思吧
呃因为从刚才的近似上来看
大家可以看到这个近似比之前的我们做了什么
tcs要更大胆多了吧
嗯ok嗯行
那咱们这里嗯就继续下一个话题了
那就是环境光照
那是这样哈
大家看到现在才开始进展这么一个话题有点晚
诶嗯这样吧
很有可能我我讲这块就讲一半吧
因为后面来说
行那这块儿呃
大家从标题上可以看到我们来说什么呢
哎我们要说环境光照的下
我怎么样做任何一个点
它的shading
也就是说不考虑shadow的情况下
假设这个点
它从四面八方都是可以接收到光照的好吗
嘿嘿嘿嘿
环境光照到底是干什么的呢
对吧
那么大家看到环境光照嗯
咱们之前在电子101提到过这个事情啊
它其实呢就是说我可以用一张图来记录
在场景中
我往任何一个方向看
可以看到的光照对吧
这样就没问题了
那这个中间呢它就隐含着一个概念
认为这个光照都是无限远的
来自于无限远的好吧
然后就是说它并不能帮助大家定义一个
我放置两个不同的物体
这俩物体放置的位置不一样
但是他们接收到的环境光照却是完全相同的
因为这个环境光照
我们认为它是从无穷远处来啊
这么个意思
这也就意味着如果你有一个环境嗯
这个所谓贴图吧
然后他中间有有一个桌子
然后你是不可能把一个什么东西给放在
这桌子上的
你要因为他会认为这桌子离呃
这个物体不管你放在哪儿
它都是无限远的
所以看不管是任何的环境
光照去渲染任何的物体
你看看着总是一种漂浮的一种现象啊
咱们之前说过
就是说所谓怎么理解这种distant lighting啊
这么个意思
假设无限远好
那么它的两种存储方式
主流的存储方式
一个叫做spherical map
一个叫cube map
各自的优缺点咱们就不再多说了啊
因为咱们这个课上就认为说好我不同的方向上
我能得到不同的这些光照就好了行吗行
那这样一来呢
我们要研究的问题也就出来了
那给你一个环境光照呃
我现在我要放一个物体在这个场景中间
那我不考虑遮挡的情况下
这些阴影的情况下
我如何去把它的shading给算出来呢
这种这种呃操作啊
在工业界被叫做i b l
也就是image base lighting啊
不怎么证实这种说法
其实嗯略大了一点哈
我个人来说
并不是百分之百能够接受这种命名方式
但是这毕竟大家就这么用了哈
i b l或者就是environment lighting的意思啊
那么呃就是说我们现在要解决的
自然就是我刚才问的这个问题吗
就是说给了你i b l了
或者环境光照了
然后你任何一个物体
或者说吧任何物体上的任何一个shading point
你如何去把它的shading的值给拿到啊
这么个意思
那自然而然对吧
自然而然大家就知道我肯定是要解running equation
running equation
咱们之前在忘了第三节课的第二节课
咱们提到过这事儿对吧
render equation在实时渲染中间
我们通常会愿意把这个visibility像拆出来
然后这样的话呢
这个lighting就表示发光的这个lighting
而不是实际到达的lighting
那么这里我既然又不考虑visibility
那这里就等于是环境光照
它来自四面八方的光照li对吧
呃就是这一项
然后呢呃他是任何一个方向都有可能有光照的
但是呢由于我们的这个呃
running in quin的定义对吧
任何一个shading point
我当时只是考虑它的来自它的正的半球
它的光照了对吧
这就是之前咱们说过什么call 3项
前面要加一个max 0嘛对吧
大家还记得这事
或者说我定义它的积分域在上半球
这上半球不上半球
定义是由这个学龄point的法间定义的啊
就是合法线呃
点乘是正的这个方向啊
那咱们把这个说清楚
那么这样一来的话
基本上来说就是我要解决
从所有的方向都有可能有光照对吧
这个这个光照是多少呢
i b l已经定义了
我要把这个式子解出来
就那么多少
对不对
ok那这里呢就是就是我要解决的一个问题
那那么这问题怎么解对吧
这问题咱们之前在game 101就说过怎么解对吧
是一个通用的解法
那就是用蒙特卡洛积分的方式来做
蒙特卡罗怎么做
我这里不再赘述好吗
就是说对于任何的一个积分
你都可以拿任何的满足任何分布的呃
任何pdf的呃一些样本
然后我来对它做一个数值上的一个一个呃近似
并且这个近似啊
我们之前没引入过这个概念对吧
叫做无偏的
我们就说它是对的吧
好吧对的
那么呃蒙特卡罗方法大家之前做过101
就会知道它需要大量的样本
然后才能让这个结果
最后收敛到他的所谓期望的值对吗
呃就是接近它的
实际上接近他的期望的值
那么这里自然就会引入说我如果真的这么去做
那大家想一想整个一个场景
那里面任何的物体或者说任何物体的顶点
或者说任何像素我都要做一遍这个解
这么一个来自四面八方的光照
这么一个渲染方程
那是不是非常麻烦呀对吧
我任何一个shading point
或者说任何一个fragment我都要做一遍
蒙德卡罗
那还得了啊
那得有多少个sample对吗
那自然而然造成的结果就会非常的慢对吧
那哈哈
所以说呢通常我们会认为只要是在shader里面
如果大家平常写这些shader的话
写的特别是fragment shader
这里面一旦出现了三link
那么这个方法就很可能会不能被
用在实时渲染中
但是诶大家看到我这里又加了个新号
这就是为了跟大家说一下
因为最近几年内我之前说过
就是说关于这块嗯
整个temporal的这一系列东西的进展啊
就是嗯呃时间和空间的这些滤波的方式
使得越来越多的这种基于sampling的方法
可以得到在实时渲染中的应用了
是这么个意思
所以说这里跟大家说清楚
这只是大家以前会这么认为
现在不一定啊
不过我们在这里呃肯定有一点是这么说的
就是说那我能不采样
那当然那是最好对吧
那所以说呢咱们呃不管说现在呃
这三个是不是真的能做
那我们还是希望能够避免它
那这就是我们要问的一个核心问题好吧
在i b l的情况下
任何一个点的shading
我能不能不通过采样来算啊
行那么这样一来呢
我们来说一下
就是说啊一个基本的思路是什么好吧
那这个基本思路从什么开始呢
是要从一个最最简单的一个观察上来看
咱们刚才看什么来着
刚才那个公式啊
咱们再回到刚才那样的
刚才在这个rendering equation里面
我们看到在积分里面是不是有两项对吧
诶等一下不是这样哈
唉真糟糕出来了
好嘞哎
ok大家看这个公式里面哈
嗯既然不考虑visibility
那么这里面它是不是两个函数相乘
这两个函数就框出来这两块对吧
一个是lighting
一个是b r d f项
我们之前说过b r d f项有时候就连着cos
那咱们这里就连着cos啊
lighting和b2 d f
那么这两块相乘再积分啊
它是这么一个呃情况
那咱们刚才说这个观察是什么来着
这个观察是这样的
就是说啊如果说诶我这个这个积分里面
我的b2 d f是一个比较glossy的b2 d f
然后我现在在渲染一幅图
相当于我固定了我看的这个视角相当于incident
这块呃就是确定了嘛
哦另外一点是这样的
在实时渲染中啊
大家通常说这incident
incident的时候没有那么严格
大家不会认为说是一定得是这个光照的方向
才叫incident
如果说我去看一个什么东西的话
那我这个目光这块也算是incident了
基本上来说这块用的比较混乱吧
这样说
但是咱们就这么说吧
就是至少咱们在不引起这些呃混淆的情况下
咱们就这么理解
没有问题啊
我们看的这个方向
假如说这是incident啊
然后唉这种情况下
那b2 d f这个logo
如果他是gloy的b r d f
那大家看左边这幅示意图
那如果他是glc的情况下
就意味着说啊
他其实覆盖了球面上的这个范围
覆盖挺小的吧对吧
然后呢嗯如果说这个b2 d f呢是diffuse
diffub 2 d f什么特性啊
如果你有入射光影
你看过来对吧
然后他们往四面八方反射
那也就是说
它其实在球面上会覆盖整个半球的区域
那它覆盖的区域非常大
但是呢虽然它覆盖整个区域非常大
但是他却非常smooth
咱们之前说过了对吧
它非常smooth
就意味着它的值的变化不大
而它的值的变化真的不大
因为它的它的值是常数对吗
就算是我们连上这个cos一项对吧
那也它也仅仅是一个cos
这样一个相对平滑的一种过渡
所以说哎我们看这两个情况
如果b2 d f是停gloy的情况
那他support就行
如果b d f是diffuse
它就smooth诶
这个事情是不是大家听起来非常熟悉对吧
哎
所以说这个时候呢
我们又要提之前提到的这么一个经典的一个
近似方案了
但是大家看这个呃公式咱们之前不是提到过嘛
对不对
然后这里注意一点哈
就是说咱们显示的把这个所谓的support给写出来了
就是说我不是要把两个函数的乘积积分出来吗
我可以把其中一个拿到外面去
就是这里把f拿到外面去
那我把f拿到外面去呢
诶呃我这里就是说我要对f进行一个积分
并且除以说他的这个这个积分线的这个空积分
之前咱们都解释过说为什么对吧
然后诶这里我把f拿出去之后
我这个积分线其实应该写作对这个这个g函数
它对应的这么一个support的范围啊
这么个意思就是说如果它范围很小的话
我不需要记整个这个范围
我只需要记这个在这个g函数有值的地方
它的这个范围就好了
那这里算是一个一点点的不一样
那么为什么要提这个事情呢
是因为刚才问了大家这个问题对吧
刚才大家发现这b2 d f的这么两个性质
是不是非常像
我们之前说这个公式什么时候会比较准确对吧
诶刚那之前说这个这个公式什么时候比较准呢
这个g s的support比较小的情况下
或者呢是在是在啊
这个g的值比较smooth的情况下
让我们发现这种情况下
对于b2 d f来说
b2 d f非常满足这个性质
那也就是说我们是可以做一个拆分的
大家来看b r d f正是能满足这两个呃
这这两个函数的乘积
并且积分他们拆出来的一个条件对吧
然后呢唉这种情况下
我就可以把除了b r d f以外的
另外一项给拿出来
还记得吧对吧
b r d f类比于这里的gx嘛
那拿出来的是fx嘛
那我对应的f是什么呢
那就是这里的光照咯
那这里的光照我就说我把光照拆出来
是光照在b2 d f范围内的一个积分去除以呃
这个光照的一个在b呃
在这个b2 d f覆盖范围内的一个空的积分
去做这个所谓normalization对吧
所以说我们完全可以这么做呀
我又把它给拆出来了
是
那么这里面呢跟大家区分一个概念吧
大家还记得之前咱们在解释这阴影的时候对吧
我们解释阴影的时候
我说这里拆出来的是什么东西啊
这里拆出来的是这visibility项哈
我是把这个lighting和这个b d f都留留在里面
把这个当做记象
所以说啊这个公式是可以根据需要来选用的啊
这么个意思好吧
那这里的应用是不一样的啊
我们这里把light给拆出来
那我把light拆出来
大家看这个黄色的这个框到底做了件什么事呢
对吧
这个框它貌似是这样的
他和这个b r d f一点关系也没有了
这是他拆出来的好处对吧
我们为什么要把它拆出来啊
正是因为说他们在一块综合作用
这light的b2 d f综合作用挺难的
我考虑不了
那我现在把light单独拆出来
我发现就是在light所表示的整个一个球上
哎b r d f这个logo所覆盖的某个区域
我把这个区域的light给积积分起来
并且我把他normalize
其实呢那所说的事情是什么呢
就是说我要把这个idl表示的这张图给模糊了
对不对
什么叫模糊
任何一个点上
取它周围的一片范围
然后我把这片范围的这个平均值给写回这个点
对吧
咱们之前说过
那所以说呃之前把light拆出来
其实他就定义了一种操作叫做filtering
我可以去所谓滤波我的环境光
而滤波的和取多大
那这个就是说我的b r d f应该占多大
是不是这意思
这是非常非常有道理的一件事情
而且大家看我这里的用词叫prefiltering
那么prefiltering是什么意思呢
意思就是说哦我这张图我在渲染之前
我就老早之前我就可以把它给掀filter好
那大家可以看到
比如说我这里这同样的这么一个环境光
那这个环境光我可以把它任何一个位置
我都取它周围的某一个大小
然后我把它filter
然后得到另外一张新的图
然后呢
我甚至还可以说我我用非常不同的大小的这些
这些呃
呃滤波的这些核
大家可以看到我用不同的这些滤波的核
去近似它
或者说
也就是说我对这个函数滤波的这么一个区域啊
就是b r d f覆盖的区域啊
呃它越大
那我这个得到的这个filter最后的结果就越糊
但是不管怎么样
这几张图我都是最早最早在running之前
我只要有了这个环境光之后
我就立刻可以先花点时间生成的对吧
所以说我在渲染的实际过程中
我是不用管它的
那这非常好啊
对不对
然后呢
那有同学说如果我到时候想去查询
说哦我这样一个呃lighting函数
然后他用某一种这个滤波和
大概呃大概比如说半径是五
然后我应该在哪一张图上去查呢
哎这个时候大家就会发现
这个概念和那之前我们说的mip map
是非常非常相似的
对不对
我可以先生成几张图
这些图呢他们各自这些呃
filter都各自filter多大呢
比如说filter 1
filter 2
filter 4
然后filter 8
那我要fter 5的话
哎我就我就在filter 4和filter 8
中间再插插值一下就可以了对吧
非常像这个三线性插值
所以没问题
这也是工业界的常用套路哈
如果说我需要嗯去这中间查询某一个什么东西
我就是用这种插值方式来做啊
没任何问题呃
那也就是说我的lighting
是可以先去做不同大小的filter
到时候我要用的时候
我到时候去查它就可以了
而且我查的不只是离散的一些filter
kernel的一些预计算过了的值
我可以去呃
查他任意的一个大小的一个filter之后的值
非常不错啊
这个这么一个思路
所以啊我们刚才说做这个拆分能够干什么呢
就是能够让你的lighting做一个所谓的prefiltering
那我做这个profiltering干什么
对不对
诶这里就是哈哈哈哈
这里就是就是说我们为什么要用它了啊
这里就是建立在一个非常非常有意思的
一个观察上
什么观察大家看还是这么一个这手绘的图啊
大家看左边这幅
左边这幅是什么呢
左边这幅是大家从某个方向看一个shading point
他的dr df呢应该是某种lob对吗
是是某一种logo
然后我们如果要真正精准的把它给算出来
怎么办
我去采样这个b2 d f的logo
我我在这个b d f logo的周围这一点范围内
根据他的glassness嘛或者ravenous嘛
我在这个周围去分布一些这些呃
采样诶
我采样最后的值
我可以做一个加权的平均
然后我是不是就可以得到我这个shading point
的值了
对不对
那这个操作是不是
就好像说我把这个嗯这个environlight
大家看右边这幅图
我先做好了一个filtering
是不是
就好像说我把environment lighting先做好一个filtering
然后大家可以看任何一个点
都是它周围一系列点的加权平均对吧
然后我再直接就去查一次在哪
在哪个方向查呢
在镜面反射的方向上去查
大家看这两个操作
是不是非常相似的一个操作了
对不对
大家可以看到
如果说我去呃呃看向某个shading point
我认为如果它是镜子
那它镜面反射方向是什么
诶
我往这个镜面反射方向去
我反射方向去
那我查我只能查一个值
但没关系
我查的只是我之前老早就已经fter好了的值
就好像是我查了他周围的一片纸一样
是不是非常聪明的一个做法
对不对
那也就是说啊我们呃这样的话
这个lighting这个前面这一部分啊
就是说咱们刚才不是把这个整个一个呃
函数给拆成了
这么这不是函数积分拆成俩积分嘛
那前面这一半咱们解决了前面这一段
对不对
我我首先我可以我对他做pre filtering
然后这样的话我就理论上我可以查他呃
任何多大的一块区域内
filter出来的结果是多少的对吧
然后呢我在实际用它的时候
我要取它的原本的light上面
它周围的某一片的值的时候
诶
我就直接可以取它的这个镜面反射方向
我就取一次值
非常好对吧
唉所以说这是这是挺好的一件事情啊
然后呢这里这样吧
我先停一下啊
我看有同学有没有问什么问题的啊
ok嗯有同学问hdr imap是不是spherical map
是的啊
没问题
然后有同学问spherical map的话
它它每一个像素表示的立体角是不一样
所以你是不是不应该对吧
不应该对这个图做一个所谓uniform的一个filter
对
没问题哈
我刚才所说的意思
你取多大的filter和这个这个大小多大
其实指的是不同的立体角哈
这么理解
或者说在球面上的一个filter的某个范围
就是你最后要把它给转换到这个呃
每个像素上
它大概要filter什么样的形状
什么样的大小
那都是不一样的哈
但不管怎么样
这是预计算
咱们说清楚是在在球面上做一个filter
那当然这个就和你实际上用那多大的图图
这个分辨率不同的位置描述它
那就是那这个就没关系了
好吧
就是说呃
只要保证这个filter是在球面上发生的就好了
那么呃漫反射是不是全图的平均可以没问题
你也可以用normal方向上的平均呃
就是说是这个意思啊
就是漫反射它不是往各个方向都去嘛对吧
然后这样的话
你就可以认为他的这个中心的方向
或者说对于漫反射
如果有个镜面反射方向啊
这话说的好矛盾的
没关系
就是说它的logo的中心方向不就是normal吗
你就沿着normal去查就好了
也没有什么问题啊
就是说嗯不管怎么样吧
呃在实时渲染中
通常人们会认为漫反射
一个是一个挺特殊的一种一种情况啊
就是说呃肯定会有的同学问
那我这个glossy logo我要不断变rap
不断变rap的情况
他不就变成嗯嗯diffuse了吗
那我其实不是还得沿着他的
然后呃就是就是镜面反射方向去查啊
这个没什么关系啊
通常人们会认为
把diffuse和glc这些东西给拆开了
这么理解好啊
呃程序化的h e r i纹理能不能这么做
除非它本身支持一个嗯动态的一个范围查询啊
按说按说我之前有些工作可以用在这个上面
再说吧
再说吧啊这算是比较深的一个话题了
ok按照已知的b2 d f来做filter啊
我觉得同学们问得好没错
这就是说你得按照一系列已知的形状的
b2 d f
但是呢正常b2 d f lob
或者说这种其实是一个反射出来的
这个logo都比较像一个什么高斯嘛
正常有一个近似
差不多了
就ok啊
ok啊
ok那行吧
差不多呃
这就是同学们的问题哈
ok那咱们继续
哎呀
我想了想该怎么办呢
哎呀哎呀
这下面这一步其实还挺麻烦的
我啊快速的说完吧好吧
这样嗯破罐破摔了
我来同学们
ok哎行吧
我们刚才做了什么呢
我们刚才把这个嗯呃积分嘛对吧
我们把这个积分拆成了两半诶
并且我们还能把前面一半给完美的解决了
刚才看到了吗
看前面一半已经没有采样了
是不是前面一半没有采样了
可是这个问题没能完全解决呢
是不是哈哈哈哈
这个问题要想解决的话
我后面这一半的这个积分
是不是也得不采样采集
是不是
这是一个非常非常重大的一件事情
就是我虽然现在把它拆出来了
但是我后面一半我还不知道要怎么做呢
那么后面一半该怎么做呢
后面一半
大家可以看起来这个事情非常的麻烦呀
这是要对整个一个b2 d f进行一个积分
那么这块呢呃首先我先跟大家说一下
现在呢是有比这个更好的解决方案啊
比比现在这个呃
就是所谓这里跟大家说的这么一个方法
更好的解决方案
但是咱们现在就先说一下这个方法怎么做好
就是右边这个红框里面
我怎么样才能把它给解出来
并且我还不能积分呢
诶那这个时候呢我们就说呃
我是可以做一个什么呢
可以做一个所谓
跟刚才的一个完全一样的思想和预计算的啊
这么个意思
就是说
只不过这里的预计算呢可能就比较麻烦了
因为这里面大家看诶
我要想算这么一个积分
我势必要把这个所有的这些参数的可能性
都可以考虑进去对吧
它是一个通用的一个b2 d f
他b2 d f写进去
那b2 d f的话
我也许说我可以做一些假设
我假设他是microphy b r d f
如果大家还记得的话
在game 101我提到对吧
嗯microphy b2 df的话
他唉我就只需要定义基本上最重要的两件事情
第一for now还记得吗
一for now
for now是能够也就是叫什么菲涅尔项嘛
能够决定说他的这个基础反射率
以及在什么grading angle下
或者换一句话说
它反射出来的这些颜色各不相同对吧
随着你不同的入射角度
这是for now
另外一个它的嗯所谓呃n d f对吧
也就是说他的那些微表面的法线分布
那微表面的法线分布
它就是一个很简单的一个一维函数
他直接可以拿所谓roughness
就是说它的粗糙度来描述它
所以说如果我假设说嗯
它是一个呃microphy b2 d f
那它能不能让我的计算变得简单一些呢
呃呃然后答案是还是挺麻烦的
如果我想把这么一个积分啊
在所有可能的参数的不同组合之下
我都要把它的值给算出来
这是一个非常浩大的工程
大家看这个事情啊
就是说咱们说the roughness
roughness是一个数啊
算是一个一维的一个数
那么feral term这个很麻烦诶
for nim
它本身他得告诉你
你这个比如说基础的这个反射率
然后它本身就有一个某种曲线对吧
它在不同的入射角度下
所以它还是入射角度的某一个某一个函数
所以这样一数的话
它就是至少是一个五维的
一个非常高的一个参数空间对吧
这样这样说就是参数有多少个对吧
那就表示这个参数空间有多大
那对于每一组不同的参数的组合
我都要算出这么一个积分的一个值
这不就是我说的所谓暴力的一个预计
算的一个思路嘛
对不对
那诶这块是有点不好的对吧
那这太大了
我要打一个5v的表格还得了啊
就是大家知道说我们三维的纹理
为什么用那么少
因为三维的纹理已经会产生一个呃
这个组合的爆炸的一个一个存储量呢
那四维五维更是如此了
对不对
那所以我肯定不能这么无脑的这么预计算嘛
对吧
唉但是我这这就是人们聪明的地方
人们会想出来一些这些更好的方式
来做这个预计算
但在这之前呢
我先跟大家说一下
从这节课开始就有大量的预计算相关的内容了
甚至是之后要跟大家说的所谓p r t precomputed
radiance transfer
这个预计算什么
辐射传输
可能这么翻译吧
然后就是说这整个预计算它是相当于有一个嗯
相当于支撑了整个游戏界的发展啊
所以说预计算是一个非常正常的一个做法
只不过人们可能不能承受非常高维度
高这个参数的这个维度的一个呃预计算方式啊
咱们这么说明白
那这里就是它不能预计算对吧
那不能预计算怎么办呢
我们想办法让它能预计算好吧
这么一个思路
在这之前呢
先给大家看一下
咱们之前game 101里面的东西啊
gm 101咱们有过这么一样啊
说microfsb 2 d f是干什么的
如果他就忘了
microfc b d f里面最重要就是这两项吧
就是一个fernal term
决定了说呢哎我这呃如果垂直看向物体表面
它有多多少能量被反射
当然这就决定了颜色对吧
另外一块呢就是说我如果不垂直会怎么样
它嗯反射的量肯定会各不相同嘛
所以它直接会决定了颜色
这么个意思啊
final term挺复杂的一个函数
然后呢
另外一个重要的东西就是说它的微表面的分布
微表面啊
微表面的法线分布
如果这个分布比较呃
就是比较开x面八方都有
那这个表面肯定就是diffuse了
那如果说这些法线它都集中在某个方向
那基本上这个就是比较接近镜面了
对不对
那所以说他就是这么一个思路哈
那么中间shadowing main还是一样
咱们不提
那么为什么这里要说一下这个事
是因为我们之后在那里说所谓p b2
physically based on
诶那叫你这个二是什么
还是rendering呢
但这里难道不应该叫材质吗
啊没关系吧
反正就是说之后再说到这个实时渲染
中间材质的时候
我们还会提
这里就简单回顾一下gg 11啊
这个意思
那么我们关注的就主要就是ferne
想和这个呃n d f项
就是这个df和d啊
呃其他的我们都不考虑问题
问题不大啊
在这里那么好
那么这两项啊
如果大家还记得这些图的话啊
之前我们说过啊
有一个能够近似的描述菲涅尔项的一个近似啊
这个近似叫做slex proximation
之前我们曾经在game 101说过这事啊
然后它近似成什么呢
他会发现这个fernal项目
它在不同的入射角度的情况下
它其实它长得都比较像这么一个诶
往上涨的一个指数函数
所以它就把它给近似成了一个指数函数
定义了一个什么呢
定义了一个初始的反射率二零
然后又定义了一个他怎么往上涨
就是那一减cos c它的五次方
大家看我故意圈出来这么两个哨哈
这这两个是什么东西
这两个其实就是对于slicks approximation
他认为啊不同的材质呃
它基本就会就就是说呃他的呃
飞鸟像是这么两个东西的函数
一个是它的基础反射率二零对吧
然后它是一个颜色嘛对吧
另外一个呢就是它的入射角度就是这个thea
然后呢呃在这里再多跟大家说一下
在实时渲染中啊
通常人们提到这几个角度都是可以互换的啊
非常非常近似什么角度
入射角也就是入射光与法线的夹角
还有出射角也是相当于是出射光和法线的夹角
还有这个半角
所谓half angle就是入射光和出射光夹角的一半
然后或者说入射光以及出射光各自对
所谓half vector半程向量中间的夹角
这几个夹角大家都可以认为差不多啊
然后所以说这里我就简单的用一个c塔
来描述了这么个意思好吗
那所以这是我描述不同的材质
不同的microsd的材质想定义它颜色就这两点
第一基础反射率基础颜色吧
可以这么理解r0
然后第二就是随着这个c塔这往上涨
你得你得知道他的这个入射角度
否则你得出来对吧
这两个变量
那么另外一点
如果我要在microfit model里面
我要想定义某一种法线分布诶
那我要定义这种法线分布的话
呃
我就要把这些法线分布的这些什么角度啊
都给描述成为一个分布
那这个分布是一个非常简单的一维的一个分布
大家可以看到基本上就是右边
大家看到一个比较类似于高斯的一个分布
就是基本上沿着他的这个宏观的法线呃
这个这个周围它分布的比较多
对不对
然后呢他这在其他地方啊
它分布比较少
差不多是这么个意思吧
然后还是一样
它公式挺复杂的
挺复杂的
但是呢大家可以看到
就比如说对于这种所谓backman的一个分布啊
这有各种各样不同的分布的定义嘛
咱们就以它为例啊
他这里定义了什么呢
大家呃呃不是他这里有什么变量呢
大家可以看到第一有一个变量叫alpha
可以可以定义所谓roughness
也就是这个分布啊
它的是胖还是瘦啊
就决定了说我这个材质呢它到底是diffuse呢
还是gloy对吧
这肯定要定义的
那么另外一个呢他还需要这个角度
也就是这个角度呢
差不多就是他那个啊half vector和这个什么呢
和这个呃法线中间这些夹角啊这么个意思
然后这个角度呢大家也可以把它给呃
通过某些近似的什么方式
把它给描述成跟入射角相关的一个角度
这个角度各自之间都比较好好呃
互换哈
都是这么个意思啊
那那么这里面我就把这些sea什么都给圈出来
当做同一个颜色来把它圈出来啊
这么个意思啊
ok那这里我为什么圈出来这些颜色呢
大家可以看到哦
就所谓入射角度
我们我们可以认为这是一个变量
然后呢我基础反射率是一个变量呃
这个呃物体的粗糙程度是一个变量
那么这样一来
如果我想还是一样
预计算刚才的那么一个积分啊
我对于所有可能的这么的参数
这么一个形成一个空间
我的每一个点我都计算出来一个
这个计算出来的值是不是这个意思
那也就是说现在变成了一个三维的一个
预计算了
是吧啊哈哈
如果这个r我可以认为它是一个灰度的话
这样的话那大家看到不同的颜色
红色的
橙色的和蓝色的
这三个变量各自都可以变化的
然后每一种组合
我都可以计算出来一个预计算结果
那当然好了
但是呢仍然唉三维的一个计算太麻烦了
那这里呢就是说关于呃这个人们聪明的地方
人们发现这么一个事情
就是说人们还想更进一步的把这个预计算的
这些参数的维度啊给降了下去
就这么个思路啊
然后呃那这是什么意思呢
基本上来说大家可以看到哈
就是说呃我的这个呃还用刚才这么一个思路
我现在在这么一个积分里面
这个积分里面有三个变量
我需要考虑
我能不能想办法
把其中一个变量再给拆到这个公式外面去哈
这里数学东西稍微多那么一点点啊
但是思路是清楚的
没问题吧
如果我想预计算这么一个呃积分的值
它的参数空间非常的高维
我是不是要想办法降维
就是这个意思了
我希望说这个积分的值
它不太依赖于更多的参数
只希望它依赖于一个比较少的数嘛
这个意思
那么这里呢就是人们聪明的地方
人们发现了这个呃
菲涅尔像这finale term
如果我把它写成用这个呃呃史莱克啊
这个这个这个近似啊
用他这种近似方式
我是可以写出一个诶哈哈哈
大家看哈
我是可以把它把这个这个积分啊
这也是呃右半边那个积分啊
可以把这个积分给写成这个形式
这个形式大家看起来非常云
没问题没问题哈
但是我想说这个近似是非常简单的一个近似
他做了件什么事啊
他在这个啊b r d f里面
它显示的把这个菲涅尔项给写出来了
大家看到b2 d f除以f
大家在右边啊
我把鼠标圈一下
大家看b r d f除以f再乘以f
是不是等于完全没变对吗
那么这个f呢
菲涅尔像咱们刚才说了
又可以写成r0
加上什么一减cos i c到呃五次方
再乘以什么东西对吧
然后这样的话呢大家就会发现哦
我把这个f通过呃
fernal term通过呃
我可以把它拆出来啊
这么写出来写出来这个值肯定是就是近似的嘛
但是差不多嘛对吧
然后呢呃这有什么好处呢
这一个好处
那就是说我可以把这个公式里面
我刚才拆出来之后
我可以把这个公式里面一切跟这些基础反射率
r0 相关的项目都可以把它拆出来
因为r0 它算是一个常数
这么个意思啊
就是说我对于任何一种b2 d f
我给你了一个r0
这个r0 是一样的
所以说我我就直接把刚才的ferno的这个
这个公式带到b r d f里面
我整理一下
我就可以把这个r0 给拆掉
积分到外面去啊
这么个意思
然后呢
那这样的话大家会看到诶
这个积分现在变成了俩积分对吧
是而零乘某个积分加上另外某个积分
o是不是听起来变麻烦了呢
答案是并不是这样
反而让结果变简单了
为什么呢
因为他把这个原本的这个积分
对于基础反射率的依赖给消除了
他把这个基础反射率拆出来了
这之后剩下来里面就是两个变量
哪两个呢
第一是roughness b r d f的roughness
第二就是它的入射角c塔i
或者说cos c塔i没关系
那我如果说我想对第一个拆出来的
这第一部分啊
呃积分呃做一个预计算
那我只需要对呃两个呃参数形成的一个呃
形成了一个什么呢
形成一张表对吧
我可以写成一张表
rance它的取值12345678啊
这样啊大概是什么意思
然后比如说它的cos c塔i
它的取值00.10.2
一直到多少
我打了那么一张表出来
这张表上的每一个值
就对应着我这个积分出来的一个值对吗
这不管什么积分再复杂出来
这是一个数啊对吧
还有一个值
那另外这边积分我是不是也能这么算
没问题吧
哎那也就是说我这两个积分我都可以把它打成
一个二维的一个表格什么呢
大家可以看这里
就是说这两个积分中的任何一个
我都可以做一个roughness和cos theta
这里大家看到theta v跟si一回事啊
在实时渲染中不怎么区分等这么一个表格哎
作为这么一个表格中任何一个点
它的值就是我算出来的积分的这么一个值
是不是也可以啊
没问题
那么算成积分这个值之后诶
我有一个二维的一张表格
我是不是可以把它存成一个二维的数组呀
二维的数组
然后它的任何一个位置上都有一个值对吗
哎那反映在实时渲染里面
它不就是一张纹理吗
我把这张纹理就先给预计算出来
到时候我把他送到shader里面
我该用它的时候
我只管去查
我就立刻可以得到这这个公式啊
和下面这么一个公式
它的值是多少
甚至每个基数还是一个数
我用一张纹理了
前两个通道
一个r通道
一个g通道
他就可以表示他们了
是不是
然后这样一来的话呢
大家看如果我到时候给你一种b2 df
他的这个基础反射率知道拆出来了
然后我我只需要去查两次这张表
诶
我就立刻可以得到
刚才我们说拆出来的右边的积分了
诶大家发现什么问题
是不是又没有采样了
对不对
所以说呢这里是这样哈
就是说如果有同学说这块呢呃会觉得有点麻烦
那是因为你对这个之前的这个microphy
可能是忘了
是这么回事啊
就是说呃基本上来说
他的思路是非常非常清楚的
我就是想预计算这个积分成为一个表格
我又不希望计算出来
也一个就是非常高维的一张表格
然后中间某一个值是多少
然后我就是希望把这些呃变量之间的这些联系
都给拆开
所以说人们就用了这么一个方式
至于说中间这个数学呢就挺神奇的
对不对
那这也是说这个方法为什么得到广泛应用
因为他确实是对于环境的这个光照来说
如果要算shading
它就再也不需要采样了
是非常非常厉害的啊
这么个意思好
那么我们这个时候呢总结一下
那通过刚才咱们说的这两种不同的两个部分吧
分别不同的处理
然后我们就可以做到说哦
我我终于就不需要采样了
我还可以在环境光下渲染这个不同的物体
大家可以看到哦
那他得到了一个非常非常好的一个呃
呃一个什么呢
一个结果对吧
大家看到这个方法
然后呢和所谓的reference reference呢
咱们就理解成是pasting出来了吧好吧
然后和这个相比
那大家可以看到结果非常非常相似
不管是呃diffuse的情况
还是说呃glossy的一些情况对吧
那那那就说明它非常好了
那么在最后呢这里呢跟大家说一下
说这个方法是有名字的什么呢
刚才咱们不是说那个积分是拆出来了
变成俩积分嘛
不过在工业界呢
通常人们很少就这么写这些积分什么的
在这个offline那个月
大家写这些积分什么的
写的多哈
在这实时领域
大家平常就写成求和了
就是大家看这里面呢
这个求和其实就是和这个什么呢
积分呃描述的完全一样的事情啊
这个求和是
那么既然他做了两件事情
第一他要把这个一个积分给拆拆开
或者说把一个求和式给拆开
然后呢他对两边呢又分别进行
之前咱们说要么filter
要么去查表对吧
然后分别进行求和
于是呢这种方法本身他就有了一个名字
叫做split sum方式啊
它不叫split integral
也是这么个原因啊
然后split sum呢是大名鼎鼎的
这个按real引擎的这个呃
为什么他的所谓p b2
可以做到这么牛的一个基础吧
就是说他这边的这个环境光照
然后在这个split sum下
然后大家可以看到呃
做的是完完全全没有任何noise对吧
他没有采样嘛
当然没有noise
然后它又可以得到跟这个真实的这个结果
非常非常相近的一个结果
所以非常的厉害o
那这里基本上咱们就把这个所谓split sum
方法就说完了好吧
那行呗
嗯基本上这块儿我来看看吧
有同学有什么问题吗
好吧哎呀
我看问题挺少
说明什么
说明这块大家不好懂对吧哈哈ok没关系没关系
真的就是把这个呃所谓high level
这个想法可以想清楚就好了行吧
然后嗯然后有同学问菲涅尔像是要去预计算吗
不是同学
菲涅尔像被我们拆开了呀
正是因为我们把它拆开了
所以说我们才会能够避免说这个啊
就是说它对不同的这些这些变量的这种依赖性
我们也可以把它拆开嘛
这么一个思路
有人说环境光本身怎么计算这块
我没看没看懂哈
没看懂什么意思
怎么获得一门max吗
那是另外一回事了啊
ok然后啊ok哦我说呃
有同学问刚才讲的更好的方法是什么
我更好的方法其实是这个意思啊
就是它并不是严格意义上来说
能够直接解决这个问题的哈
是是呃叫做linear cosine transform吗
它跟这个相关
跟这个相关之后
我们再讲的时候
我们再说吧
好吧啊
ltc啊
这块应该大家听过
ok然后来看看哈啊这张预计算图是不是固定的
是的哎
这就是非常好的事情
它对于任何不同的b2 d f
只要是同一种种类的b2 d f吧对吧
然后这张预算出来的图是一个固定的
所以说你只需要把这一张图传进去
你对于各种各样这个类型的
microphy的图都可以了对吧
l t c是是可以说的
没问题啊
o l t c不要把它想狭隘了
不是只能算面面光源哈
啊这个之后再说吧
之后再说吧
好吧嗯ok啊
来看看哈
嗯对b d e f不同
你算出来这个图也不同
确实是这样的
然后microfit在gg x里面会多参数
不会啊
也是这么写参数啊
除了d l s s吧
其他东西甚至连dnoising
现在大家用的都不太怎么多
目前来说并不怎么成功哈
这个之前我说过这个事情
这个事情是可理解的
实在太慢了
你跑一遍神经网络下来需要几毫秒
这不是已经死了吗
那怎么怎么用嘛对吧
这就呃呃
特别是说
如果说你要是在比如说shading的层面上
每一个点都要跑一遍神经网络
那就完蛋了
根本不可能的嘛
对吧嗯当然这是我说的
现在不知道以后会不会怎么样哈
ok其他b2 d f相关资料哎
跟这个暂时关系不大吧
咱们到pb 2的那块再说吧好吧
然后cos和b2 d f连在一起
为什么啊
这是因为咱们在这个课的开头讲过哈
大概不是第二节
第三节我忘了哈
k i b l适用于什么场景啊
确实有同学已经回答了
适用于你想用的场景啊
没任何问题
任何场景啊
就是用的特别的多啊
i b l有问题
我之前说过
就是因为它会假设所有东西都是无限远的嘛
对于一定和你的物体有一定的确定距离的
像这种光照
所以不能再这么用了哈
ok我刚才有同学问
求和是分母的p是什么意思啊
那个就是我们在蒙特卡洛积分中间的
pdf那块来说
你就只需要看game 101
你就知道那是什么意思了
好吧嗯
大概是18讲左右吧
我忘了
ok i b要怎么处理遮挡
问得好
同学看这里哈哈哈
这里就是说关于环境光照
我们的遮挡怎么样去处理啊
这里怎么样去处理
我就不说了
这节课已经时间挺多的
他然后咱们呃这下节课再给大家说
因为这块其实怎么说啊
直接一个总结
就是没什么好办法啊
ok嗯ok然后积分里分母的f怎么计算
哎同学是这个意思
积分里那个分母啊
仅仅是为了把它写出来
大家想一想
那个分子上f乘以g乘以d
那再除以f不就消掉了嘛
就是没必要计算嘛
对不对
然后b2 d f本身f乘以g乘以d
你下面又除了个f不就直接消掉了f了吗
对吧
ok那行diffuse和glossy项目还可以再拆分的
有很多这个后续的处理了
咱们就不再多说了好吧
ok那是这样哈
咱们说一下下节课的话
咱们就要开始说实时的全局光照了哈
关于全局光照
这块儿是指非常非常复杂的一个话题
它会比阴影这块还要难啊
然后基本上来说我做了一个简单总结
差不多分为三类
一个是在3d的空间中
我怎么样用这些方法
然后一个是在图像空间中
怎么样去引入全局光照
然后最后一个就是说关于预计预计预计算
然后我想着呢下节课如果没有意外的话
我们会先说这个三维的空间中间的一些方法
比如大家看到这些这些缩写都是什么鬼对吧
l p v v x g i rtx gi这种东西
哈哈o嗯行吧
然后我就到时候这个嗯资料提前看
其实是好主意
我应该想一想
把资料给放出来
哎这样吧
这样吧
这个这个我看吧
如果我不不忘的话
下节课我注意一下
我之前把这块需要的资料先给放出来好吧
那今天咱们就到这吧好吧
按说已经说了不少了
嗯ok这节课大家大家体会到了
对不对
就是之后呃我觉得不会简单的
但是你要说之后会比这节课会难到哪去
应该不会吧
反正差不多就是这个难度了哈
基本上这个意思那行啊
最后呢还是一样
谢谢大家
然后呃记得哈
下周咱们没课啊
但是这周周六还是有课的啊
就这么安排吧
行没问题啊
ok那就这样了
那我现在下播了啊啊各位同学们拜拜啊